hi I'm Julie Stanford and my superpower
is designing Technologies and
experiences that people love I wear two
hats half my time I'm at the Stanford
computer science department where I
teach Learners like you how to do
research and design for technological
change the other half my time I'm at
slice bread a Consulting agency I
founded where I practice what I preach
through my Consulting work I've
witnessed many well-intended digital
transformation projects with with low
adoption lot of headaches along the way
here's what I've learned from these
failed projects even though the term
digital transformation sounds like it's
about technology turns out the secret to
success is to shift your focus to the
people at the center if you want to make
sure that the new technologies you
introduce have long-term impact you need
to start with a human centered approach
we'll begin this course by taking a deep
dive into interview Tech techniques that
you can employ to uncover the true root
causes of problems then we'll learn how
to squeeze as much insight as we can
from that data and finally we'll cover a
systematic process for running rapid
experiments to validate your ideas and
minimize risk at every step along the
way we'll analyze case studies and
you'll work through project-based
exercises that will help you apply what
you've learned what are some of the
things you do at the beginning so
business leader Jonathan allly will
provide additional industry insights on
how to plan test and launch an effective
digital transformation what you really
have to do is step outside of your own
preconceived biases and truly listen be
willing to follow up and dig and probe
and ask why my goal is to help you
uplevel your career by teaching you how
to use human centered tools to
confidently run a successful digital
transformation project so join us from
wherever you are at Stanford
online